pour eux voilà qui va bientôt d'un 16 la
parole est à monsieur lionel tardy pour
le groupe l'est républicain
monsieur le premier ministre dimanche
nous voterons pour le second tour des
élections régionales dans treize
nouvelles régions cette refonte des
régions laisse perplexe d'autant que les
économies ne sont pas au rendez vous
le passage de 22 à 13 régions effectif
au 1er janvier 2016 avait pourtant
double objectif alléger notre
millefeuille territorial et réaliser de
substantielles économies
ce big bang régionales se voulait l'un
des volets les plus emblématiques de la
réforme territoriale lancée tambour
battant par françois hollande durant
l'été 2014 à quelques jours d'un vote
qui décidera de la couleur politique de
ces super région cette refonte
avec ses airs d' usine à gaz suscite
l'indifférence et perplexité l'absence
d'adhésion de nos concitoyens vis-à-vis
de super régions dont les centres de
décision se situeront à des centaines de
kilomètres de leur lieu de vie s'est
traduite par une abstention record
campagne oblige la surenchère de
certains candidats qui promettent par
exemple de ne pas déménager tel ou tel
service n'arrange rien à la faire d'où
la confusion voire la grande pagaille
qui entoure cette réforme qui se voulait
ambitieuse ainsi dans certaines grandes
villes
on essaie toujours pas ce qu'il
adviendra des hôtels de région ces
bâtiments souvent clinquant et onéreux
sorti de terre dans les années 80 à la
suite des lois de décentralisation
certains sont encore plus récents à
clermont-ferrand un nouvel hôtel de
région a été inauguré l'an dernier pour
80 millions
mais c'est bientôt à lyon que les
nouveaux élus de la région rhône-alpes
siègeront quant à la bouffée d'oxygène
que ce vaste chantier doit rapporter aux
caisses publiques 10 milliards
d'économies à terme selon le
gouvernement cet objectif en laisse plus
d'un sceptique l'efficacité économique
aurait dû être la priorité de cette
réforme
hélas cet argument a été oubliée par le
gouvernement il est encore temps
monsieur le premier ministre de ne pas
faire de cette réforme une occasion
manquée que comptez vous faire pour que
cette réforme territoriale réalisée en
dépit du bon sens soit au moins source
d'économies
débutez la parole et à madame la
ministre de la décentralisation et de la
fonction publique
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
député tardy
madame la présidente j'étais obsédé par
monsieur tardy madame la présidente
merci de me donner la parole poursuivant
mon service je me suis excusé j'ai bien
en fait on est à quelques jours d'un
deuxième tour où l enthousiasme des
personnes qui veulent gérer la région
quand je vous entends j'ai l'impression
qu'on fait tous demi tour et qu'on veut
pas se présenter aux élections
régionales c'est un enthousiasme
forts de nos candidats qui nous permet à
de dire nos grandes régions avec plus de
pib pour toutes avec plus de valeur
ajoutée disponibles avec plus de
compétences avec une réorganisation de
l'état qui actuellement fait l'objet
d'une concertation comme vous avez pu y
assister qui se passe bien en termes de
réorganisation de cette administration
déconcentrait que tout le monde
l'appelle de nos voeux
l'ayant région monsieur tardy qui auront
plus de moyens vont être en charge la
stratégie industrielle de la france
c'est un objet forcément de grandes
satisfactions que la plupart des
candidats ou des sortants donc je ne
comprends pas votre question à trois
jours des élections sous fait dire que
sur les lycées sur les transports sur le
développement économique sous
l'enseignement supérieur la recherche
sur l'avenir de la france nos grandes
régions vont porter une force
extraordinaire et je pense que vous vous
ne voulez pas les gérer
merci madame la ministre la séance des
questions au gouvernement et terre